à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux
pas plus chez les fous trop de peau
beauté bien sûr photo
wada pas de clown attention il me manque
un
[Musique]
papa tashnaq ce que je suis malade ou la
ramallah qu'est ce que tu as ça tu en as
pourtant pas beaucoup mangé
il a mangé tous mes gars tout pas
gourmand qui tu es puni c'est bien fait
pour lui la raison ne nous en occupons
pas si l'état dassin cueilli comme celle
de patates et je veux tout le même lui
faire une bonne terme de foin non non j
merveilleuse tisane de fleur d'oranger
et moi j'ai quelque chose de mieux
une dizaine de clous de girofle temps là
la meilleure note justement les miens le
mien le mien je suis tellement malade
que je vais prendre le 3 alors comment
te sens-tu avant mieux par le patin luc
longley tout faux pas là
attachement d'abattage pâques
mais quand il faut se tuer à défendre
pour voir où je mélange de triage nous
avons proposé un philtre magique c'est
vouloir de thomas qui fait qu'elle est
le responsable de ce 21ème siècle
moi j'entends face au jeu n'attendra pas
longtemps dont la sac à papier
[Musique]
enfin j'ai perdu ma fausse méfaits du
film ne dure que quelques midi et moi là
monsieur bougon au fica vitesse à brad
et moi notre filtre hall pendant ce
temps là je peux t'en chez moi oui passé
ce petit et frottez il a disparu
coté sur moi dont le retrouver
[Musique]
vite le foin les fleurs d'oranger et
clous de girofle fait prêt atteint but
vient boire des tisanes
j'espère que monsieur pourquoi il n'ya
pas encore attrapée qu'est ce qui se
passe si vite au vide
[Musique]
je meurent de soif
cette merveilleuse boissons m'a redonné
des forces
alou deux petits chenapans catastrophe
[Musique]
tant d'émotions bourgon
on va regarder
[Musique]
e
raté encore là c'est mieux à vous lancer
de javelot de mon enfant j'étais un
champion j'ai même reçu le javelot
d'argent en 1900 et quelqu'un a
longtemps regardé au riez riez je vais à
la ville mes amours tout je vous parie
5/4 abeilles chacun que je vous parle
tous les deux au javelot 100 membres
oui nous mettons chacun 5 carats met sur
la table et celui de nous trois qui
atteindra le centre de la simca grade
tous les gars mais vous êtes d'accord
d'accord
oui
et
[Rires]
ah mais ça je pense que nous parviennent
au caramel
je vais m'entraîner et toi t'as truc de
pata truc j'ai trouvé le truc je vais me
faire un javelot spéciale j'avais
longerich à matha plus la patache niaque
oh là là là là je veux pas perdre micah
ranum - comment je vais faire un jeu ça
avec ses tableaux à tête chercheuse
je suis sûr de gagner parce que tu vas
tu verra plus tard
o o
et oh
grâce à l'impact d'un vitesse et un jeu
sera champion que le meilleur gagne
un bel honneur mais c'est pourquoi non
d'abord le plus jeune vas-y pata zif ce
n'est pas pas régulier ça va faire comme
moi
qu'en pensez-vous pas tacle où chacun se
débrouille allez-y à moi
la voilà
[Musique]
c'est que c'est lourd oh qu'est ce que
c'est que ça les haltères pour me faire
des muscles tu mets prat mais c'est bien
trop lourd pour toi allez battant laisse
moi faire ma gymnastique
oh je commencerais tout à l'heure ne
parlons pas en noir à manches à balai le
tour est joué
[Musique]
c'est pas possible c'est pas le plus
grand qui sont les plus fins des mains
[Musique]
sales
mais tu as sûrement un secret bien sûr
lequel six un secret c'est que ça ne
sera pas pas aux pâtes à zut je t'en
prie
dis moi ton secret tiens je te promet de
réparer nos chariots dès ce soir je
mange chaque matin de couronnes de
beasain gouin a des gars de quoi de
blizzard - demi je vais immédiatement en
acheter
oooh
et oh
le grand désarroi ça n'existe pas où je
peux essayer pas où tu m'as bien sûr
mais surtout qu'on
[Musique]
moi aussi je suis très fort aux haltères
roux ou la mairie tazoult tu as secret
c'est même un très grand secret dis-le
moi sans caramel et joli ces chers
attend tous est donc bon eh eh bien je
t'écoute le crâne de busan voire trois
fois par jour
et
encore un battra peaux à teint mat a dû
[Musique]
batailler
j'ai fait tous les magasins de la ville
je n'ai pas trouvé de graines de beasain
gouin je suis sans larmes avoir ta là là
je suis là on a hâte à zut j'ai trouvé
le secret du blizzard loin semble pas un
ara n'oublie pas que tu me dois 5,1 à
mais ici pas de vibrations attention mes
chers auditeurs dans 55 minutes clôture
de notre grand concours de chant
j veux tu serais sûrement la meilleure
ah non ce match at amiens pardon pardon
j'ai une très belle voix bien placé nous
ferons tous très bien
nous allons répéter et nous irons en 30
ans ville devant le micro géo commence
trois mois
cuire mois
tél
m
[Musique]
les
non
moi
bah
[Musique]
non
ouais
[Musique]
bravo à mon tour maintenant
le père qui est beaucoup plus
[Musique]
où
ou presque
puis c'est tout
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce vacarme
nous répétons pour concours de chant
vous avez de la chance que souhaite
bonne humeur de très bonne humeur
continuez continuez à moi moi attention
je recommence
[Musique]
ma passion
l'équipe a beaucoup de familles ne
cherchez pas cela
ça n'apportera pas chez
[Musique]
c'est très drôle très drôle
je m'amuse beaucoup et monsieur bonbons
rien continue je vous écoute avocate
aclu a pu attendait plus rien ne t'a pas
cela ferait avec turenne papa tacle ou
encore dans l'hérault
demain je mets ma tête dans les mains
mais je répète c'est le truc avec un
truc avec les clés rien n'est tabou
l'a fait avec du rêve comme mata clos on
peut recréer la
inutile et coûter cher vous allez
entendre le mcr dynamique en europe je
crie fait de bruit d'un moment on est
des plus content on était loin de
prudence est que mon temps
on était tous
on était loin de papa plus de patache
marque ça se trouve fort
rien ne sert de bien chanter il faut
partir à point
[Musique]
papa car je m'ennuie pas pas car je
m'ennuie pas si je lui ai pas vus jamie
est aujourd'hui avec moi dit le bon
assieds toi là maintenant je m'entends
tu as fait tu te tais et tu écoutes une
très belle histoire au silence il était
devant elle elle était devant lui
les étés il est devant l'autre ces bacs
tintin histoire ému et s'y sentir
heureux kc sainte irène
[Musique]
patate loup je mens nous fait comme moi
d'or j'ai pas ça me vient jouer avec moi
l'on joue tout ce en quoi est ce que tu
veux
j'ai pas dit de installe toi un bateau
et fichman ap mais quel genre de bateau
bon ben j'ai compris j'ai compris
[Musique]
je crois que ça non plus ce n'était pas
une bonne idée ne peut pas se faire tu
apprends sa force en dentelle blanche
jay chine natale heures lapierre a pas
de cette mer et vous à la pêche la
mémoire
[Musique]
apache ou quand un bateau quoi à bâteaux
un bâteau dans le jardin je t'ai dit de
jouer tout seul chez moi dormir
[Rires]
pourtant j'ai bien vu un bateau
[Musique]
j'ai vu un tableau pirates à la fenêtre
regarde je vois surtout un affreux petit
menteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
jean l'ovule aux pirates j'en ai vu
voler vous tu verras bien qu'il n'ya
rien
[Musique]
ça vous apprendra à faire moins de bruit
[Rires]
il est vraiment beau votre sapin
et puis vous savez nous avons appris une
chanson de man a je vous écoute
1 2 3 4
[Musique]
jamais
la travail
invités
nabeul
oh
amis
e
ouais
j'espère que vous ne le changerez pas
toute la nuit
bonsoir
[Musique]
en tout cas moi ça plus je ne dors pas
je veux voir le pardon le père noël ne
vient pas tant que les enfants ne sont
pas couchés
[Applaudissements]
on va voir ce que l'on va voir
qu'est ce que tu veux faire je vois deux
coupons plein cela permet autant dans le
tout j'arrive
mais c'est très méchant il va se faire
mal il peut se casser une jambe fois je
vais chercher autre chose
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as dans la main packs
loue aulas pour quoi faire
pour le sommet dans la cheminée la
parole marche au dessus se pique au jeu
j'arrive il sera tellement furieux qui
remportera tout s'est joué ce sera comme
ça
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as encore trouvé dans
la cale
je vais en mettre partout ils se collent
de pied les lamas matin j'arrive et
comme ça les autres petits enfants sont
privés de jouer c'est très gentil sable
où tu en es tu joues pas tu as plus je
dois pas parce qu'à 15 jours pourra bien
faire pour le voir bien monsieur bourbon
a oublié sa canne pas tant que ça va
le banal entre sa part le pida la
ficelle ce qui fait on de la classe à la
bazoge arrive ça c'est rigolo je vais
t'aider
[Musique]
maintenant tout le monde au lit
par mathieu bougon
que faites vous là mais j'étais venu
chasser maken et qu'est ce que c'est que
cette cloche mais on n'est pas à pâques
noël opaque
c'est toujours une fête ont tendance à
la vente en passant la barre cependant
ce n'est pas le père noël tu vois bien
que c'est monsieur bougon banias ce
parement de 12 ans les enfants qui va
briller comme un vrai soleil pas tamoul
de baliser un pro bowl a frotté en
voiture on vas tu pâte à tarte étendre
le linge dans le jardin attention aux
états unis
il y avait même deux circule toujours la
même chose
fantasme at on jamais ou allemand le
plus tu crois pas que c'est de ta faute
fabre du palonnier regarde jamais ce
genre talent cette patate à bâle toi à
moi c'est pas pareil je suis petit
je ne tape pas passer d'affaires
attention sans moi et puis d'abord à
leur apporter
c'est pile de linge mal comme ça avoir
mal aux pieds aux benjamins à 12 ans
mais toujours aussi distrait pas ta zut
et la distraction
ça provoque des accidents encore là haut
le port marchand c'est très dangereux
la prendre si ça continue faudra aller
se promener sac à son tour ah ah
comme ça pas de risque de tamponnement
nous allons faire une petite balade pata
roule ça te va ben moi je vais dire moi
je lis pas un marchand mademoiselle bien
sûr tu ne sais pas lire monsieur moi par
contre je me souviens très bien des
images en direct you le poison
attention monsieur mais pas à rouler
failli me raser faut dire que nous
avancions et nbc wigan on ne lui avait
pas d' excuses
le musée de nature est en état de rouler
tout marche de travers si c'est pas vrai
peut-être aubin les bakwa quoi il ya des
problèmes bon et bien qui dit problème
dissolution c'est à vous de vous
débrouiller truc de pâtes a cru que ma
pauvre pata rôle comme le couple tchèque
encore une fois roues en impasse matin
la remplace c'est bientôt fini ce boucan
alors non seulement quand on est deux on
se fait renverser par des pâtes à
roullens folie mais quand on essaie soin
de nous imposer c'est pour votre
sécurité monsieur bobor je travaille
pour vous
alors dans ce cas mon cher ami vous êtes
cette voie là avec les feux de
signalisation
fini les accidents fini les
embouteillages bon les patins pu répéter
avec moi la leçon de conduite de
l'automobiliste rouge
on ne passe pas en jonathan vermont
passe encore une fois rouge en impasse
orange en date un larron pas parfait
maintenant mais c'est beaucoup
vous êtes au volant qu'est ce que vous
faites rouge
je ne passe pas orange un temps vers le
bas bravo petit clou mais n'est pas mon
ami avec vos füle
que ce passe-t-il en cas de panne
d'électricité en cas de baisse tout le
monde parce que c'est soit à
[Rires]
[Musique]
attaquants nathan african maison à
mesure pour la bactérie papier
ap
en attaque on a passé notamment plafond
en charge un proche chance à ses jours
il est appelé à capuchon bakhta peluche
pas plus
[Musique]
bonjour ma belle nous allons être à ta
ville tous les deux pour acheter des
clous j'espère que tu es content pas
trop on dirait c'est pas mal ça se fait
mais fatigué tu n'est pourtant pas
sortie hier allez allez allez un peu de
courage pat à rôle alors qu'est ce que
c'est que ça un euro pourquoi faire du
patin rôle ce n'est pas gentil
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu dis mais non il n'y a
pas d'arbres arriver à les réveille toi
attention cette fois c'est sérieux
réveille toi et en avant dans sa patte
un rôle tu deviens folle ou quoi je te
répète qu'il n'y a pas d'arbres devant
toi voyons tu étais phare semble en bon
état tu me vois flou j'ai eu l'idée
fatah êtes attaché apporte-moi la pelle
et le râteau dans la maison non j'ai je
n'ai besoin que des manches pour quoi
faire
tu verras bien plus tôt c'est pas ta
rôle qui verra bien
bon cette fois nous allons faire un
examen sérieux alors regarde bien à la
première ligne car vois-tu pas tharoul
[Musique]
mais non pas n c'est un rat mais non pas
elle
cee lo mais inutile de continuer je sais
ce qu'ils te forme à port pata roule
[Musique]
tous
on
attention alors placé bien les branches
de chaque côté du capot voilà les verts
devant sais pas voilà j'ai bien hâte
d'en fixer le tout solidement la voilà
parfait je vois bien ma petite patte
arul voilà tes lunettes plus de
problèmes d'arbre maintenant alors 11
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais pas mal de remous
attendez
attaquants
tabbou l'avant
ma table
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez nouvelle année plus belle
mes chers amis tout est permis tout et b
non il faut je corrigeais vers les
patins plus j'en profiterai pour faire
du bruit
voyons année nouvelle année plus belle
[Musique]
moi j'ai vu un prince charmant s'amuser
avec le prato à aa
[Musique]
mon dieu le gâteau l'échappée belle
entrée bourgault wolfsburg aux bonnes
années
mes chers amis où le beau gâteau ou
trouver il m'a donné beaucoup de mal non
non non non après le spectacle a un rôle
énerve ses bonbons vous êtes notre
invité année nouvelle année plus belle
que tous vont souhait soit exaucé
je vais vous chanter le prince charmant
j'ai eu chaud
[Musique]
il est en cause
oh
au printemps
c'est tout
bon
[Musique]
maintenant les rois des claques
bravo pour terminer honneur à la grâce
au charme avec pâte à tarte
[Musique]
le gâteau ce n'est pas grave
pas grave un si beau gâteau des infos
gâteau que j'ai fait pour pouvoir danser
avec alors il n'y a pas de gâteau si le
vrai dans le four
un nom que je lui ai dit que ce n'est
pas un vrai bateau à aubes bravo pâte à
tarte
il est très bien imité l'oubli bonne
année bonne année youpi youpi
bonne année youpi youpi
non
les problèmes la pluie du tout je n'ai
vu une belle chez la marchande
[Musique]
malheureusement ma tirelire évident
les pâtes à peluches de videront voient
les leurs pour me l'acheter je suis bien
triste et riche que je vais sans doute
tombé malade attacker une lettre pour
toi merci de kiev site en anglais en
anglais et patachou pas ta vie tu veux
n'évite pas d'accord a voulu nous les
prendrons glay je n'y comprends rien
j'aime l'idée elle vient d'amérique
pataca tu connais quelques uns en
amérique
non mais ils ne connaissent que ça il
tue par mambé yes moustapha ka c'est
vrai qu'ils parlent anglais
il allait plus la lettre
chère maman jeune attaquant nous avons
appris quand vous étiez la plus belle de
toutes
et nous vous invitons à participer au
grand concours de beauté international
qui aura lieu à hollywood très
prochainement lui faut que vous soyez
prêt et élégant avec toute notre
admiration signé les brothers frein
voilà quel honneur
pourquoi pleures tu es pourquoi viejo on
va vider nos tirelire et tu sauras la
plus belle
je réussis je vais avoir une belle robe
elle suit la plus belle c'est en
français comme en anglais
je suis très inquiet vous ne faites pas
de bruit
vous n'êtes pas malade au moins non non
tout va bien nous avons reçu une lettre
en anglais au nom d'un sac à papier je
peux jeter un coup d'oeil je parle très
bien l'anglais mais bien sûr monsieur
bougon chère mademoiselle grâce au
disque de la sniffe compagnie vous
apprendrez l'anglais en vain le son ce
qui vous permettrait de comprendre cette
lettre dont la traduction vous est donné
au dos c'est ce qu'il ya d'écrit
mais oui d'ailleurs regardez au patac
heures s'est moqué de nous pour avoir
une eau remplie demain nous allons nous
venger
[Musique]
c'est la fumée qui sera la plus aisée ce
ne sera pas toi ta lettre elle est
écrite en français de l'autre côté de la
feuille regarde pour te pu dire tu feras
la vaisselle et le ménage pendant une
semaine et ta belle robe neuve on va la
donner à patates a aussi justement
elmira centrales pour faire la vaisselle
plus belle eau c'est moi
[Musique]
ou aaa à la tâche à rabat attacker j'ai
besoin des deux pour essuyer l'investor
je termine mon maquillage et je suis à
toi j'ai compris elle en a pour une
heure je crois que ça peut-elle mes yeux
la bouche
je suis tout de même plus séduisante que
papa bar quand la vaisselle je veux bien
aimé me vient et patata j'arrive on tard
j'ai fini
[Musique]
on écoute
nous allons tous vider mon tirelire et
puis nous irons à acheter des assiettes
en porcelaine au grand bazar la
porcelaine il nous avons assez d'argent
[Musique]
c'est pas bon ça à quoi ça sert à rien
c'est décoratif
ah bon oui pâtir ni la sur l'étagère tu
veux me donner des sous je veux t'en
prendre à bon oui nous devons acheter un
nouveau service de ré c'est la pâte à
tarte
je vis de guérir ou la tienne est lourde
tant mieux c'est là que je mets mes
vieux clous tu vois je suis économe
je ne jette rien il reste la ternière de
papa tu as ta zik états unis
or with il encore je sens une pièce mais
ce n'est pas pour acheter de la
vaisselle à leur sagacité zut je veux en
cash au nez ou
attendu à gaz ou pas c'est pas ta zik
oui oui mais pas tirelire je ne l'est
plus comment ça je vais c'est une pièce
je les ai perdus ou vraiment perdu oui
je suis certaine que tu mens pas
d'accord tu as ta zut prétend avoir
perdu sa tirelire
si tu nous l'as dolls autorise tous les
gâteaux gook du m
pendant une semaine mais plus que je le
parent du cherchant bien on finira bien
par l'art trulli sans eau
[Musique]
ben ça non
les
e
edit 2 3 4 5 et que j'en ai vite nous
trois pièces 2 3 4 5 est le godillot
le vide mais chaque pièce a marre des
pattes de vitesse elle bien sûr ça
n'existe pas en grand modèle mais
peut-être qu'en tirant un peu dessus
j'arrive à les mettre
et c'est de la provocation au seulement
j'ai vraiment voulu serein
dans un sac à papier les voilà partis
tout seul merci le vote
maintenant j'en vois un pain au chocolat
jeu soir le fleuve ob entendu
on en arrive là sas et de l'obéissance
je ne m'y connais pas ils me font des
potes de vitesse par n'importe quel
moyen par si le vote
maintenant on va se reposer un peu je
sens base
[Musique]
je lis tirek
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas surgi mais subira bab et
sane
[Musique]
et maintenant à moi la grande vie voyons
le problème et ne pas les lasser
ensemble car elle s'enfuiraient pour
rejoindre pata zif bon je n'aurai donc
une esclave au lieu de deux ecoute-moi
bottes
j'aimerais bien lire mon journal mon
journal nous son ca au maire qui est le
battre ici
mais il est tout déchirer essayons autre
chose un bon cigare et je serai le plus
heureux des bougon ça marche au quart de
tour
grand petit bonhomme une moitié de
cigares mais ça ne suffit pas si vous
voulez un journal au plat ou un cigare
tout entre il faut en voisin le buck et
bien bon c'est pas ta zut je me vois
obligé de te demander pardon mais
j'avais tellement envie de ses bottes
cet oubli nous allons fêter ça on
pouvant d'imbaba limonade
en asie les bottes sotra plaisir de
travailler avec toi
batta zut déjà
[Musique]
c'est bon la limonade d'uni mail
il est beau mais qu'il est faux ouah je
vends que je suis beau mais nos petits
sauts mongolienne regard des prochains
mois pour quoi faire
bonjour aux billes du foot et zut
un bijou de cette valeur aulas fera
d'auby d'un bailleur
on joue pas avec un bijou j'aimerais
bien avoir un collier comme ça
[Musique]
il faut savoir que plus jolie ne va pas
[Applaudissements]
quels conseils tu pourras me avec mon
relevé le rouge le blanc le bleu comme
tu n'as pas très bon goût je mettrai le
rouge
il ya des fois où où je regrette de
n'être pas vraiment mon sens tu te fais
tu es avec ce rouleau à pâtisserie vous
chassent les mouches les mouches
quelle mouche elles ne sont plus là
qu'est ce que veulent les effacer
la chair est atteinte non seulement tu
n'as aucun goût mais en plus tu es
complètement folle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
catastrophe ou les joues
[Musique]
oh
vous n'avez pas vu mon collier tu me
trouves plus tôt collier je l'avais
posés sur la table de la cuisine
enfin il me semble moi je n'ai rien vu
[Musique]
je la trouve dans nos valeurs et le
collier naturellement puisque je suis un
croix détective ta personne ne bouge les
mains là
[Musique]
mais cloud ne casse rien montage août ne
touche pas à ma boîte à poudre on part
vivre à vos poches
je n'ai pas de coach en tant que papa
cloud exécutions pendant que dans tout
simple jeu nos pistes le grand détective
est un petit matin on me la semaine de
mal à attaquer jusqu'au bout mais qui
vous en empêche monsieur le détective
je crois à sentir une odeur disant mon
gâteau il était en train de brûler si on
en mangeait cela nous remontrer un peu
le moral ça mais le rapace parce que ça
pendant cet été
qu'est-ce qui nous pouvons avoir toutes
qui n'a pas caché qu'un collier pourtant
faire offrir un deuxième aux coutumes me
choque pas plus que si je n'avais pas
assez de chagrin je te demande pardon
tiens je te laisse la plus grosse part
dans le danton
les barbots mon gâteau cocoyer l'avait
laissé tomber dans ma patrie c'est moins
je suis vraiment un cran victimes
[Musique]
pas gentil et mare jeté mon sac des plus
purs derrière l'escalier c'est à passer
et tu va renverser le des piqûres
[Musique]
ohlala je suis vraiment le plus
malheureux de papa j'ai un jour comme
aujourd'hui un jour où tout le monde
devra meeschaert le jour manas ne fait
pas
oui oui au sac à papier encore un ballon
dans les caraïbes où j'aurais très bien
pu me casser une jambe
c'était encore ceux ci n'apportent pas
ta suite à ta vie tu viens ici c'est la
wc bat asut anniversaire voie qui mène
un bras la jambe zamolo avoir étendu aux
poumons en bout de table
sachant qu'on apprend là c'est une
fausse au moins à ta vie bien vite on a
besoin de toi allons dépêche toi un peu
[Musique]
banana
m
[Musique]
tu croyais qu'on allait oublier ton
anniversaire un one man belgrade où les
diamants
les voilà au tous les ans voulait mais
qui a pu faire ça moi j'ai ma petite
idée
monsieur bougon qu'est-ce que vous
n'auriez pas fine sa patte à vue le
vagin embrapa c'est cadeau
d'anniversaire ont disparu et comme vous
étiez furieux contre lui du noté chez we
cacher des cadeaux via mais je vais vous
aider à les retrouver alors toujours
rien
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les patins plus je remonte chez moi
les cadeaux beau cadeau dont on les
retrouvera oui oui vous êtes fait
monsieur bougon cette fois sous les
cadeaux j'avais confondu le sac des
cadeaux à mettre celui des épluchures
voilà qui l'avait sorti de sa cachette
et oui pour mettre que des rumeurs
autour des boîtes pour que ce soit plus
joli pour faire des oubliés quand on
sait tout de même moi qui les ai trouvés
chez cadeaux ou peuvent-ils bien-être
c'est cadeau bien 3g vous qu'il y ait de
pâte à pain
il ne faut trop échos
votez bien sur vos droits moi dans ce
retour attendu
il nous manque
[Musique]